[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce
nouveau numéro de la grande interview
aujourd'hui nous allons nous intéresser
aux plateformes de jeux en ligne et plus
précisément aux techniques de
prosélytisme des mouvances radicales
en effet certains groupuscules profite
de l'engouement pour lés jeux en ligne
comme le jeu vidéo fortnight ils
l'utilisent pour se rapprocher de la
jeunesse et diffuser leurs idées pour en
parler nous avons invité le journaliste
paul conches qui a mené une enquête sur
le sujet il en a d'ailleurs tiré un
livre intitulé les grands remplacé aux
éditions art qu'est un bon jour paul
content merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation
vous l'avez dit un dans votre livre vous
êtes allés à la rencontre de ces
personnes issus des mouvances de la
droite radicale qui recrutent sur les
jeux vidéo
qu'est ce qui vous a donné l'envi déjà
de creuser cette idée écoutez c'est vrai
que l'extrême droite on savait que
depuis un moment elle s'intéressait aux
plateformes de jeux vidéo mais
généralement à s'intéresser à internet
elle s'intéressait à ces espaces en
ligne bien avant leurs adversaires c'est
vrai qu'à la fin des années 90 le
premier parti politique avoir eu son
site internet c'était le front national
et tout un tas de mouvance alors
identitaire nationaliste on pourrait
dire nativistes aussi avaient commencé à
investir les espaces comme vannes
caramail comme des espaces de discussion
et puis aujourd'hui on les retrouve sur
des logiciels plus récents comme comme
discorde
alors c'est vrai que dans le courant des
années 2010 les plateformes de jeux
vidéo sont devenues pour des rabatteurs
en d'extrême droite devraient bases
opérationnelles c'est-à-dire qu'on va
retrouver aussi bien sur des forums de
discussion entre gamer qui sont des
forums où se parle quotidiennement des
adolescents mais par dizaines de
milliers sur des espaces de discussion
plus privé comme discorde ou les jeunes
s'organisent pour jouer aux jeux vidéo
on retrouve le même phénomène mais aussi
sur des jeux en réseau comme comme le
jeu fortnight où on trouve dans les
parties des prosélytes de
de ces différents courants pourquoi
justement ces plateformes sont idéales
pour les recruteurs elle offre plusieurs
avantages déjà les plateformes de jeux
vidéo sont des espaces qui sont peu
régulé on peut y avoir une liberté
d'expression quasiment totale on a
énormément d'adolescents souvent jeunes
parfois très jeunes qui n'ont pas
forcément de culture politique
on va trouver beaucoup de gens devant
lieu du périurbain des campagnes qui
joue de manière un peu solitaire
ces gens sont parfois mécontents de la
société parfois mécontents aussi de leur
destin social
donc si des recruteurs des rabatteurs de
ces différents courants s'intéresse à
ces milieux là c'est bien parce qu'ils
ont l'impression de trouver un public
qui va être peut-être plus réceptif à
leurs idées vous êtes allés à la
rencontre de ces gamers quelles sont les
personnes que vous avez rencontrés alors
moi c'est vrai que je me suis intéressé
notamment un forum de gamer très
fréquentée qui s'appelle avait noël qui
est une espèce de forums dissidents dans
un forum peut-être que le grand public
connaît plus qui était le 18 25 du site
jeuxvideo.com ce forum dissidents à un
peu attirés au fur et à mesure tout un
tas de deux représentants de mouvance
alors on a des nationalistes des
identitaires on a même parfois des
néonazis et ils se sont appropriés cet
espace donc le forum anneaux avaient
noël c'est les dizaines de milliers de
membres c'est dépareille des dizaines de
milliers de messages postés
quotidiennement on échange on discute on
se fait des blagues et moi alors je me
suis présentée comme comme journalistes
auprès de auprès de ces jeunes gens nés
à interviewer un certain nombre le
souvenir que j'en garde c'est j'ai eu
l'impression alors pour les plus
radicaux en tout cas d'avoir affaire à
une jeunesse qui se sentait vraiment
rejetée par sa société de
espèce de public de on pourrait dire de
petits blancs entre guillemets qui sont
à la fois hostile la bombe à la
bien-pensance un déjà c'est un discours
qui revient très fréquemment chez eux et
qu'ils sont aussi au style plutôt à
l'évolution de la société plurielle
multi culturelle française
ils sont donc hostile au métissage ils
se sentent eux envoient dans votre
déclassement et certains ont carrément
l'impression de en tant qu homme blanc
de devenir vraiment minoritaire dans le
temps dans le paysage ces jeunes se sont
forgé une contre culture politique qui
voient leur donne l'impression
d'appartenir peut-être à une une élite
éclairée là qu'ils auraient un peu tout
compris de la société telle qu'elle est
actuellement qui ce sac à part des
postures très radicale qui s'approprie
aussi une rhétorique qui est très très
sulfureuse et quand on scrute leurs
échanges
on voit que la propagande raciste
il est totalement normalisés qu'elle
sait qu'elle s'incarne dans un peu la
culture du lol qui est si propre à
internet c'est un peu ce ton de la
blague ce ton du du troll d'humour noir
de provocation que les gens qui
fréquentent internet connaissent bien
bon ça l'est vraiment une contre-société
pratiquement qui souhaite pas vraiment
vivre sont les codes de l'époque paul
content
très concrètement comment ces joueurs
sont contactés ensuite attiré comment on
passe d'une partie de fortes night à une
discussion avec des groupes de mouvance
radicale
ils ont plusieurs méthodes qui ont
détaillé une par exemple alors moi
j'avais suivi pendant un certain temps
dans des espaces un peu confidentiel une
mouvance alors négationniste pour le
coup c'était quelques centaines de
personnes qui étaient rassemblés donc
sur logiciel discorde qu'il ya un espèce
de salons de discussions privées
auxquelles on accède par invitation et
depuis ce logiciel il d'identifier des
profils de joueurs sur fortnight qui
voit là les intéressés parce que
peut-être avait-il déjà un discours qui
ressemble à un petit peu aux leurres ou
du moins qui montrait des signes
d'intérêt pour disons
les thèses identitaire alors ce que j'ai
fait c'est que je les ai suivis et ce
sont en gros mêlée à la partie d'un
jeune joueur de 14 ans qui voit là je
venais du sud de la france ils se sont
mêlés à la partie ils ont joué avec lui
ils ont commencé à engager la discussion
alors il faut savoir que sur le jeu
fortnight on peut se parler au casque et
ça al'avantage justement de pouvoir
parler directement à la personne et donc
ce qu'ils ont fait c'est que ils ont
tout simplement commencer à faire des
blagues un peu antisémite voir comment
ils réagissent et sur le chat vocal ou
sur le chat écrit le demandait est ce
que tu en as pas marre des arabes
par exemple il commence à amener un peu
leurs pions à placer leurs pions et en
l'occurrence le jeune homme a commencé à
montrer des signes d'intérêt faut savoir
quoi la turista discussions se passaient
alors qu'il est en train de se tirer
dessus
c'est assez assez folklorique et à la
fin le en l'occurrence le rabatteur
d'extrême droite lui a confié un lien
d'invitation pour accéder à leur espace
de discussion le jeune homme a cliqué et
partir de là il va essayer retrouvé
exposé à toute une propagande qui l' ont
été complètement négationniste on y
retrouvait vraiment le pire des
caricatures antisémites des années 30
est aussi tout un tas d'autres discours
identitaire qu'on a l'habitude de
croiser maintenant un peu plus souvent
sur les réseaux sociaux
vous avez suivi six recruteurs vous vous
l'avez dit est ce que vous en avez
contacté certains d'entre eux est ce que
ça a été facile de leur parler et
surtout est-ce qu'ils assument c'est ce
recrutement vraiment sur les plateformes
de jeux vidéo en ligne
alors il se trouve que j'ai rencontré
physiquement un de ces de ses recruteurs
alors lui il était donc âgé d'une
quarantaine d'années il habite en ile de
france y voit les fréquenter une
mouvance suprémacistes blanche
parisienne alors pas très grand de 200
personnes à peu près et lui alors il
servait pas de forte nights il allait
sur un forum fréquenté par des jeunes
gamer lui s'est intéressé un peu leader
d'opinion c'est à dire les
les membres du forum les plus actifs
ceux qui voient là sont les plus
populaires alors il ce qui fait c'est
qui va les alpaguer les hameçons des
îles valeur écrire des messages privés
et ensuite leur proposer tout simplement
de les rencontrer les rencontrer et puis
voilà si la rencontre se passe bien il
leur explique bomba regarde voilà moi je
je milite dans telle mouvance il ya des
gens comme toi il ya des gens comme nous
alors en plus ce n'est pas seulement un
mouvement militant parce que il leur
propose aussi des cours de boxe il y
avait aussi des veines des cours de
chant des soirées des bivouacs c'est
vraiment toute une camaraderie en fait
qu'ils lui proposent
voilà et ça c'est un hameçonnage qui
pour le coup a fonctionné à merveille
ils ont réussi à recruter cette seule
mouvance parisienne ils ont réussi à
recruter 20 personnes seulement sur ce
forum en utilisant cette technique là en
vérité c'est très dur de garder la trace
de toutes ces opérations de de
prosélytisme et et de recrutement la
fictive mans j'ai eu la chance que l'un
d'eux accepte de me parler mais sur
celui qui m'a parlé combien voilà ne se
montre pas et combien ne le désirent pas
parler à la presse
est-ce que aussi vous voyez peut-être
certaines similarités avec les méthodes
de recrutement de mouvance radicale de
gauche c'est dur à dire parce que
c'était pas vraiment l'objet de mon
enquête
le fait qu'il existe des mouvances de
gauche extrême gauche qui recrutent dans
certains milieux oui alors ça
effectivement ça existe moi je me suis
beaucoup plus à même de parler des
techniques de recrutement de l'extrême
droite je peux vous parler d'eux
des royalistes par exemple les
royalistes qui sont émouvants peut-être
pas très pas très majoritaire en france
eux ont des techniques pour approcher
notamment des jeunes de l'extrême gauche
en l'occurence j'avais rencontré lors
d'un événement du mouvement monarchiste
l'action française
un jeune homme qui au départ faisait
partie de ce qu'on appelle le black
block donc le black block cette espèce
de deux groupes
entièrement vêtue de noir qui se
mélangent aux manifestations syndicales
et qui vont dans un but de voilà de deux
confrontations avec la police
et aussi pour casser les tous qui
incarnent les grandes anciennes comme mc
gaulle et les chaînes de luxe et est-ce
que aussi recrute sur internet e bro que
pas vraiment sur internet ce sont des
sont souvent des groupuscules qui font
ça de manière beaucoup plus là encore
beaucoup plus sous les radars parce que
se sachant surveillé ce sont des
mouvances qui vont quand même très très
peu sur les réseaux sociaux et les
quelques groupes que j'ai pu analyser
mais plus dans le cadre de mon travail
de journaliste
ce sont plutôt des réunions informelles
où il n'y a pas de téléphone portable où
il n'y a pas internet et où on se
pratiquement on se distribuent des
papiers qu'on lit et qu'on détruit
ensuite voyez c'est vraiment pas du tout
la même méthode aujourd'hui comment ça
se fait que ces méthodes de recrutement
échapper aux autorités
est ce que les autorités sont déjà au
courant et est-ce qu'elle regarde ça
d'un oeil attentif assez compliqué
toujours d'avoir des réponses des
autorités de leur part par rapport à ces
sujets là elles ont un intérêt certain
pour les mouvement d'ultra droite et
pour ses plus éminents représentants en
quelque sorte
il ya tout un il ya certains agents de
renseignements qui sont entièrement
dédiés à la surveillance de de ces
mouvements là après ils n'en font pas
font pas beaucoup de bruit autour de ça
il reste discret je pense qu'il vaut
mieux effectivement le rester dans ces
cas là il faut pas croire qu'elles sont
voilà en totale liberté
elles sont évidemment surveiller avant
de vous quitter
paul qu'on j'aimerais qu'on fasse un peu
votre bilan le bilan de cette cette
enquête que vous avez mené
racontez nous un petit peu ce bilan que
vous vous en faites c'est vrai que j'ai
été très surpris de voir le nombre de
militants d'extrême droite qui avait
choisi de recruter en ligne je n'avais
vraiment aucune idée que c'était aussi
nombreux que j'avais aucune idée de leur
technique de recrutement j'ai essayé de
les développer dans mon livre j'ai été
sidéré aussi de voir qu'il existait donc
des français insiste suffisamment disons
incompatible avec le multiculturalisme
qu'ils étaient prêts à tout quitter pour
recommencer tout ailleurs et disons
aussi plus généralement ce livre fait
vraiment le constat qu'il existe un soft
power de droite radicale qui
n'existaient pas forcément avant ils ont
vraiment une prise assez sidérante à
laquelle moi je ne m'attendais pas du
tout en commençant cette enquête merci
paul content d'avoir accepté notre
invitation aujourd'hui je rappelle que
vous publiez les grands remplacé aux
éditions marquées elles cette émission
est à revoir sur notre site internet
arte france point tv à écouter également
en podcast merci de votre fidélité et à
très bientôt chez arte france
[Musique]